justo aquí he traficado la función de la
fx y la gráfica en este intervalo que
bueno podríamos pensar que es del 0 a
algún valor positivo digamos no sea
algún número a ahora quiero que pensemos
en el valor máximo y mínimo en la
gráfica de hecho ya hemos hablado un
poco sobre máximos y mínimos absolutos y
esos son bastante obvios pues por
ejemplo aquí el el máximo se alcanza al
inicio que podríamos pensar que es el
cero y el mínimo se encuentra en el otro
extremo digamos en este valor positivo y
muy bien entonces lo que quiero que
pensemos o más bien que observemos es
que hay otros puntos que se ven
interesantes ay ay ay por ejemplo un
punto como es este que también es
interesante y realmente podemos pensar
que este de aquí es mayor que otros
relativamente cercanos a este muy bien
entonces por ejemplo este es un valor
este es un valor ce y la función digamos
toma un valor fdc muy bien entonces si
ves la geometría digamos de la gráfica
tu puedes ver que este está muy por
arriba alrededor de varios por ejemplo
también puedes ver que este punto de
aquí digamos vamos a llamarle de y que
su valor sea sea digamos
efe de este valor efe de está por abajo
de varios puntos que están cercanos muy
bien
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es llamar
a este valor
fcc fcc tiene un nombre muy bien
fcc tiene por su digamos su
característica principal de que es más
grande que varios que están cercanos de
ese entonces decimos que fdc es un valor
máximo es un valor máximo vamos a
ponerlo aquí es un valor máximo relativo
relativo y el relativo hace porque
cerquita de ese va a ser mucho más
grande que todos esos valores que estén
cerca de c lo mismo podemos decir para
el valor efe de entonces a este valor
efe lo podemos llamar de forma análoga
verdad
fd es un valor mínimo relativo mínimo
relativo muy bien relativo entonces
esencialmente la idea que nos dicen es
cerquita de estos puntos la la función
vale mucho más que los que están
cerquita y en el caso del mínimo vale
menos que los que están cerquita ahora
como explicamos esto o como escribimos
esto matemáticamente ahí te baja
entonces decimos que fcc es un valor
máximo es un valor es es un valor máximo
relativo relativo
aunque es un máximo relativo si la
función evaluada en ese punto es más
grande que los que están cerca es decir
sí fdc es mayor o igual que fx para para
para todo
x y podríamos pensar que x esté cercano
hace muy bien pero perdí esto queda muy
ambiguo verdad porque tú podrías decir
bueno y qué significa que x sea cercano
a nuestro valor c entonces piénsalo de
esta forma que va a existir un intervalo
un intervalo digamos aquí tenemos c y
aquí vamos a tener un intervalo en donde
todos estos puntos todos estos puntos
que están en este intervalo están por
debajo del valor de fcc entonces esto
quiere decir que para todo x entre
digamos se menos h y c + h ok
pasa esto que fs es mayor o igual que fx
donde además la h
es mayor que 0 muy bien entonces
esencialmente estamos diciendo que todos
los que están cerquita de ese es decir
que se encuentran en este pequeño
intervalo ok que se aleja hacia la
izquierda ya la derecha h unidades para
todos estos van a estar por debajo de
este valor
fcc ahora te invito a que hagas una
pausa y entonces escribas tú mismo cuál
sería la definición de un mínimo
relativo
entonces podríamos decir que fdd es un
mínimo es un valor es un valor valor
mínimo relativo relativo
ahora efe de es más chico o igual que fx
para todo para todo x que se encuentre
en algún intervalo de menos h de más h
con de mayor que 0 muy bien entonces
allí tienen las dos definiciones así que
esencialmente fdc es un máximo relativo
si es más grande que todos los que estén
cercanos a c es decir que localmente
sean de un máximo y fdd es un valor
mínimo relativo si localmente son mínimo
es decir que en algún intervalo digamos
en algún intervalo para todos esos
valores que se encuentren en el
intervalo fdd es el más chico